it's a very popular part of the valley
it continues to grow we're talking about
summerlin yeah now plans for a new
housing project in the neighborhood of
summerlin southwest mary jane belliesa
tells us more about the future of this
area this dirt lot will soon be home to
almost 100 thousand residents the howard
hughes corporation has been developing
summerlin for more than 30 years you can
expect to see that expansion continue
brian walsh of the howard hughes
corporation says this most recent sale
follows a tremendous need for housing in
the las vegas valley started looking at
it a year ago and talking to builders a
year ago on how it will come together
and then they're closing in december so
it's really different than really a
different bulk sale than what we've done
before pulte homes and toll brothers are
working together to build the site it's
just a bulk sale which means it's gross
acres 216 acres for 135 million dollars
and it closed december and this
development is right off tropicana and
south town center drive we also require
a lot of the builders in terms of extra
design features and
recreational
additions to the community all of those
kinds of things tom warden also with
howard hughes says these considerations
also include having a gated community
the type of home traffic and proximity
to businesses we know and make sure that
we understand what kind of homes are
going to go in there so that there's not
going to be competition between other
areas of summerlin developers anticipate
breaking ground in march reporting in
summerlin mary jane vallieza live local
now
we can also tell you that development is
expected to have more than 560 homes